but this question really touches on
something that you brought up before
which is that there are many wisdom
traditions over thousands of years
that have said very very similar things
and and and and
in some sense as a scientist i'm sort of
a johnny come lately right
science is sort of a johnny come lately
to this but but the science is
is coming along but but
the kind of answer to the question that
you just raised
will require
that we take all the insights from the
wisdom traditions
and then we also take the rigors of the
scientific method
in terms of theory building and careful
testing
and bring these together in a
synergistic interaction so that we
we find out from the wisdom traditions
deep deep insights but they they were
there first in terms of saying
space-time is not fundamental like the
physical world is not fundamental
and they've given us some informal
pointers
to what might be beyond right there's no
mathematics there there are
right so now that now the johnny come
lately
science and hey we now
now we realize that space time is doomed
that there's something deeper
and we can now start to build
mathematical models that try to capture
some of the insights of the wisdom
traditions
and we can have this back and forth now
between our intuitions on the one hand
and then our attempts to make them
precise and why do we do that is it just
to be pedantic
and to be you know over the top with
mathematic it's not that at all
it's that in some sense
you don't really know what you're saying
until you say it so precisely that you
could be wrong
that's when you are beginning to know
what you're saying so
we will use in informal words you know
in in the wisdom traditions including
words like god
and if i ask you precisely what's the
definition of god
you won't find it anywhere so um
what we need to do is
to try to make these intuitive ideas
that the
christians have their probably genuine
insights make them absolutely precise
so that we can then learn and be
surprised like
so for einstein for example in i think
around 1907 or so he had this
fundamental insight about gravity
that if he was in something like an
elevator that was free-falling
that you would you would find and you
had a you know
something that could weigh you in the
elevator you'd find that you were
weightless you wouldn't weigh anything
inside the elevator
and he said that was like the happiest
thought of his life because it was
it was the insight that gave him the
general theory of relativity but it took
him something like
eight years of
struggle really
tough emotional struggle sleepless
nights
pulling the hair out kind of kind of
stuff to turn that
insight into finally in 1915 or
something like that
he got he wrote down the equation and
that's what it really means to say if i
was in an elevator i would be weightless
but what it and the reason you do it now
is because then
the mathematics is smarter than the
person who wrote it down
that mathematics that einstein wrote
down
he didn't know it but it entailed
the existence of black holes and when
someone else
a year later after he published it some
uh some guy in the front lines of world
war one actually
working on the equations discovered um
this guy named shortshield discovered
this solution to einstein's equations
that there are these black holes and
einstein did not like it he disbelieved
in black holes for decades
so here's a case where we write down
our we take our ideas including these
deep spiritual ideas that we've had for
thousands of years
we write them down mathematically not
merely to be petatic
so that we can actually learn what we
were talking about all along
falling in an elevator and being
weightless means there are black holes
well who would have ever figured that
out and so the things that we say in the
wisdom traditions
they're going to mean all sorts of other
things that we had no clue that they
meant
until we get serious and write them down
so that's why
i want to see this synergistic
interaction between science and
spirituality where we take the insights
from the one
and the rigor of the other and then
we learn we get surprised and that's
that's that's the hope
wow yeah that's so well articulated
um the you you said this in another
um in another way as well that you
become a student
of your theory that the equations become
smarter than the genius that wrote them
down
that right you're just it's so
spot on um that that the the the flag
that we plant beyond the edge of
knowledge that we create hypotheses
towards
that just flowers a whole nother field
that we weren't
ready for we didn't know yet existed and
the signs of spirituality are those two
driving forces that have gotten us
um so far and that to where we are and
so to bring them
together and harmoniously test them i
like using the
the description where you think about
like what have we done the manhattan
project
and dropped nuclear bombs on hiroshima
nagasaki if
our science community was a little bit
more spiritually ethically morally
philosophically
awakened but would we also would we
would we um would would we have all of
the pedaling of snake oils
if our scientific method was stronger to
analyze those
um snake oil salesmen so there's there's
that
as well so there these things they they
they come
together like peanut butter and jelly
okay they could and i you know there's
been this long-standing um
antipathy between science and
spirituality that it
has some interesting historical roots in
particular for example the
the treatment of galileo by the catholic
church
i mean and and and alan turing even in
the last uh 100
years yeah and that was yeah
that was um a society that was
um that really cruelly attacked him for
being homosexual sexual yeah
right so so in in so so there's been
this long standing antipathy
between science and spirituality at
least since galileo and
the catholic church and and
giordano bruno burned at the stake
exactly that's the kind of stuff that
that we don't want to have happening and
and that's why
it's it's really critical to walk away
from dogmatism
yeah right that's that's dogmatism is
the source
source of all this and it you know it
seems like um
most spiritual traditions would
recognize that humility
is a virtue and i would include
in that humility about my beliefs
humility that i could be wrong um and
especially when we have hundreds of
different religious systems
many of which in the past have said that
i'm right and all the other religions
are wrong
now now we know that at most one of
those hundreds
could be right right and and what's the
probability that it's mine and so
so instead of going in that whole
framework it's rather
why not have an attitude of right
whatever the ultimate reality is surely
there's compassion for my ignorance
and for what i got wrong and there's it
it's
and surely the the the most
healthy way for us to proceed is to
listen to each other
and to share i don't have to believe
what you say you don't have to believe
what i
say but but i also don't need to kill
you if you just disagree with me
you don't need to kill me if i disagree
you know and
instead we can have this this humility
to listen
maybe agree to disagree um and then
maybe
later on in 10 years i realized oh i was
deeply wrong
and you know sharon over there she was
deeply right and i just didn't see it at
the time but i've grown up and now i see
it
so so just giving ourselves the time and
the space
to to grow up and to to learn
uh humbly and and that's the way i feel
about the science i mean i
i'll say this i love scientific theories
the i study them they're incredibly
beautiful and i don't think i've ever
seen a true
scientific theory i think all scientific
theories that i've studied so far are
deeply false
they're the best we have so far yeah but
they're good enough in many cases to
tell us
where they're false and that's the power
of a theory
where it tells you where it gets off and
that's what i want in spirituality
there's a therian spirituality that's
good enough to tell me
where it is inadequate and where it's
beckoning me
to now go for a deeper theory with a
different level of understanding but
it's all new inadequacies
and girdle is suggesting that we will be
doing this forever
don i feel like the
the edge pushing that's happening around
um bringing together signs of
spirituality the edge pushing
that's happening around um understanding
our source code
that that the the topics that we've
talked about
and understanding that ultimate
reality um i i feel like
um the word integral and integrality
are a very important um phrase there
because of
um just it the integral and the
derivative but the integral in the sense
of the integration
of all um perspective but the
derivation in the sense of the um each
one of us having a unique
experience in that candy store um so
yeah yeah and and in a unique artistic
contribution or gift to bring to the
world and
and um that that's that's the 99.9
genetic similarity integral and the 0.1
genetic difference differentiation um
so that yeah yeah go ahead absolutely i
i think you've raised an
incredibly important point to view each
person that you meet
as a gift they have a new perspective
that's different from yours and rather
than
putting up barriers to things that are
foreign and novel to recognize that
here's a chance for me to explore
something
that i that i might not have ever ever
explored
without interacting with this person and
you know
this person maybe i'm a geek that likes
mathematics
and this person is an artist who likes
painting and photography
um i can learn from their perspective
and they they can learn
from mine and and i can appreciate um
if i'm willing to open up and humbly
listen and and really
listen because i may not have the
concepts yet
i may not have the point of view
to really understand what that person is
saying
yeah in which case um is even
more important for me to put in the time
and effort because i'm gonna have more
to learn there there's more
that i can can grow from that so so
having that kind of view of our
differences that they're an opportunity
to learn
to expand our horizons
and to realize that that in some sense
perhaps is what life is all about is
constantly expanding our horizons and
constantly
enjoying new vistas yes this is that
we've had
we like to sit in our investors and say
this is it yeah hey you know that next
mountain may have something even more
fun
yeah the constant exploration of the
infinity candy store
i love this it seems to make the most
sense of the alternative being we
already are
all of the infinite candy store
combinatorics
um eternally happening and that has a
little bit more of maybe a
nihilistic eternal return sense to it
that we've been here before we're doing
this again um
but the the other one the idea that
there is
just it's never going to end the
infinite exploration
um it has a little bit more adventure
and it has a little bit more
darwinian metaphysical implications to
it as well where
we need to take this seriously we need
to take our
um rock orbiting of the star very
seriously because
if if as above so below another
spiritual wisdom
is true that's also scientifically
validated that if natural selection is
happening here between
us natural section is all could also be
happening at this cosmic level not only
in our universes but universe says
competing against one another for that
recursion
and how likely it is that that they
themselves get to those next
tastes in the the qualia uh
candy store that's quite possible that
would be something i would really like
to explore in this dynamics and graphs
of conscious agents to see what
what in the world is going on here and
what kind of dynamics are we using maybe
to explore the candy store
absolutely yeah don i'm so so grateful
for this conversation thank you thank
you for everything that you're doing
and that you've inspired so many people
to think
in refreshing and new ways and push the
edge of what's known
we're very grateful to you thank you
into all your lab
to all your students and lab and
teammates um as well that that's very
important the people behind the groove
of the song
right oh absolutely i couldn't have done
it without my graduate students and my
my collaborators you know you know and i
can name a bunch of them that that
frankly um push my ideas around all the
time and that's how i learn